Speaker 1: Let's go next to I hope
I'm pronouncing this correctly. Is it
Govind in Los Angeles or Govind? Govind.
Los Angeles, please, on mute, Govind
Govind. Can you hear me now? Just barely.
That's a little bit better.
Speaker 4: Oh, yeah, so, yeah, I was wondering
what your thoughts on the mainstream media like.
They're basically like, what do you think they're
lying on Afghanistan? Like basically like even
CNN and MSNBC, they're breaking on. I mean,
they're breaking with Biden on Afghanistan.
Speaker 1: So what lie with
what lie do you think they might be telling
Speaker 4: all their lies, spreading like pro-war,
like they're being very pro-war, like Jake Tapper
up from CNN. He he brought on Tony Blinken and
then he was like, why don't we just say stay
there for more time? Like, yeah. And you're
also still trusting the generals who we know
are, like, really dumb and like they are also
keep spreading propaganda.
Speaker 1: So what what
propaganda did the general spread?
Speaker 4: Well, like they're like,
oh, we need to stay there for more time. Because
because because because if we stay there for more
time, the Taliban will come in, even though if
we unless we stay there forever, like forever,
the Taliban will just come in.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, listen,
staying there forever, it's like what
the hell are we doing? It makes no sense.
Speaker 4: So my view from the military
industrial complex through and then CNN
and MSNBC are listening to these people.
Speaker 1: I to be perfectly honest,
I just got back and I've everything I've consumed
about Afghanistan has been me reading I was
reading on my flight back earlier this week and
all of this. So I don't know. I don't know. Nor
do I care that much. I mean, I want to see what
the media narrative is, but I'm guessing Fox is
basically saying, oh, Biden, Biden blew it, even
though Trump had the plan to do the exact same
thing. But let me look into what is being said in
media. I've just really been reading my news about
Afghanistan. But I what you're saying sounds
like you're saying they're taking a position
that you don't like rather than they're lying.
I'm not I haven't heard you assert any lies.
Speaker 4: Well, well, they've been listening
to the generals who have been lying, I think
Speaker 1: the generals have lied, OK. All
right. Well, let me look into that. I mean,
listen, it wouldn't be a shock if corporate
media was taking some kind of position that
progressives don't like. That would not
be new. Let's put it that way. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. All right, my friend, thank you so much for
the call. Glad we got the audio sorted out there.